ich will man keine provokation du gehst
auch beide seiten gebe ich gerne wenn
wir beide beiden jahren konzentriert ihr
zu stören
erst richtig probiert mit frau ja mit
frau geschlafen
wenn jetzt mit dem partner das werde ich
das für möglich es können und wir haben
sich nie zugestanden dass ich schwul bin
ich merke man schon im umfang von daehre
ganze produktion für der seinen doktor
dass es eben nicht normal ist dass den
schiedsrichter in die super league
soccer und der öffentlichkeit gold und
aus geldnot sehr viel zu
[Musik]
also ich sauber danke es wird nicht so
für immer fehle jetzt im vorfeld denkt
und ob sie jetzt nach einer sachen
innere die schwulen oder so also dabei
habe ich schon ganz anders als
spekulativ und den fans war die mutter
also dass ich es geschrieben
ja
dieser fußball-schiedsrichter tritt aus
dem schatten und bricht ein tabu
pascal erlachner 37 jahre alt er ist der
erste spitzenschiedsrichter der offen zu
seiner homosexualität steht aufgewachsen
in wangen bei olten hauptberuflich
turnlehrer daneben privatpilot ein film
über einen menschen auf dem weg zu sich
selbst über sein letztes großes coming
out
lausanne letzten sonntag spiel eins nach
dem öffentlichen coming out bedarf für
cs spiel jede super league weiter nach
dem outing hat stimmt kommt
ravensburg
ich werde genau wie ich das spiel leider
wenig voran gemacht hatte minister
versuche sinne von arglos sich ruhig als
wenn sie brauchte probiert sie probiere
ich die richtigen entscheide 2
er wird versuchen das alte gelände umher
die nicht groß zieht waren der macho das
danke es kommt so schnell
[Musik]
schwule fußballer ein großes tabu auch
bei uns immer noch
der erste fußballer der öffentlich zu
seinem schwulsein steht justin fahnung
der brite spielt in der premier league
verdient da millionen
er zerbricht am immensen druck und nimmt
sich 1998 das leben
thomas hitzlsberger 1 captain der
deutschen nationalmannschaft gewinner
von wm und em medaillen er outet sich
vor drei jahren nach seiner
profikarriere
das mediale echo ist groß einen
nachhaltigen einfluss auf die
wahrnehmung schwule fußballer hat sein
coming-out jedoch nicht und die
schiedsrichter nur wenige leben ihre
homosexualität offen
rhesus tommy etwa aus der spanischen
regionalliga fans beschimpfen ihn nach
dem coming out ja drohen ihm eine zeit
lang steht er unter polizeischutz
heute pfeift er nicht mehr zu groß ist
die angst und das in einem land in dem
homosexuelle heiraten und kinder
adoptieren können
der fussball
gerade der männerfußball hat sich dem
thema homosexualität noch nicht geöffnet
coming out werden helfen das tabu zu
brechen
ein fußballer dort aus homosexuellen
autors aber das ist mini rein subjektive
sicht will fußballerischen tolle schöne
tattoos nicht jeder aber das ist ein
trend dass auch wieder teil der körper
ist perfekt - einander nuss oder sich
gegenüber früheren und darum hat man
alles toll sollten die frauen aber das
gehört alles mit seinem status im
profifußball
rené erlachner ist garagist schon mit 20
wurde er vater
pascal ist das erste kind von ihm und
seiner frau margit pascal erlachner
wurde mitten in die karriere seines
vaters hineingeboren
dieser war junioren-nationalspieler und
spielte unter anderem bei den berner
young boys ein attraktiver fußball
aktien attraktive trainer sowohl trophy
entstanden sind und nach einer aus
jugendlichen noch nie fahren und
vielleicht auch der tolle frau
verbringen und die frau bringen also
beweglich leander studiert dort ironisch
als versager geführt wo immer
weitermachen oder nicht verletzen und
das völlig blöd die erinnerung dass sie
dass sie das modell aber das hat es im
moment zu dem zeitpunkt könnte
[Musik]
im hockenheimer hat ja mit drei treffern
knoblauch oder ja diesen tipp topp aber
du bist ja aber es ist schön so und
faris karten ab rappen manches ich sage
und brachte ich nicht so bescheiden sie
aber sicher sollte wurde im standard
entspricht ausgestellt
links
das ist auch genau so
wernigerode
der moment überhaupt nicht zusammen sind
sei riesig so häufig sehen ist mal
sicher häufiger als die papierbasierte
am gleichen ort wohnt wie nicht sein ich
also mit 20 gb ab geworden und haben
doch waren waren die ganze zeit die
familie über wasser halten und keine
sorge das ist gott aus kanada sehr lange
und die hypothek mit sieben große pikant
das ist eine ganz schöne objekte so
jungen eltern wort dass er den großen
pelé doch sehr viele abdecken mit einem
mitmieter
schulz kanton luzern
als karl begleitet seinen vater zu einer
meisterschaft spiegel
er ist trainer in der ersten liga
denn wunder films mit gold bin ich total
schockiert dass taylor habe die vorwürfe
gemacht dass sie das initiative und das
was sich leicht ab und zu gespürt dann
nicht direkt angesprochen haben denn
vielleicht war schlichtweg froh dass das
jetzt schlussendlich gemacht und
beschlossen also das macht sich sehr
brisant weil ein schiedsrichter und der
schiedsrichter ist im fokus von gut und
schlecht und fein ist die schiedsrichter
meisten schwächeln und ich könnte mir
vorstellen dass das alles vielleicht
sogar über schied aus weil ich weiß wie
das funktioniert und es ist eine frage
für ihn und von dem moment wo das das
nicht sicher mit der brust
wie sie in der schweiz schon recht wie
das thema homosexualität betrifft aber
natürlich ein spieler angst vor der
reaktion von der kollege schwer
vorstellbar dass der kollege das war
sagt sie
bis pascal erlachner selber den mut fand
die ersten schritte auf diesem weg zu
gehen dauerte es lange
also ja relativ jung merkt dass sie
anders steht es ist fertig hätte ganz
viel gut die kollegen auf wenn ich
möchte das ist ein herz ich verliere
verliere und die hände und warum höre
jetzt jedes so das knie ist der hand in
hand oder so oft vor dass dipascali frau
ist in ried gehört und aber groß
gedanken gemacht hat man sich der bass
geschäfte passau sowie eine zweite
identität aufbaut hat zum beispiel als
zwei cent erhalten kontakte
dank der politik fehlt ja das mit dem 2
1 das courier
wie häufig sie bewirkt sehr oft einsam
seehofer würde ich wirklich bin ich
verliere ich habe das nicht einfach
nicht schuldig fühlen
seit mein kann man kann nicht mehr in
frage nach gott direkt und zu aber japan
wieder gespürt dass nichts das geradezu
im alter vor der pubertät so im
jugendlichen alter eher schwierig sie
gerade im fußball und in utah
wenn es darum geht im umgang mit den
kollegen die absprache habe ich das
schon gemacht aber immer reden wir immer
gespürt
es ist nicht das niveau das wir
abbrechen ich trenne zu gestalten
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich dass kuka jetzt ist es
soweit jetzt muss ich das mache das
outing mit riskanterer racing sind im
restaurant das sich zusammen und ihm
selbst geschichte schrieben
es tut mir leid dass die haut und so ne
in hospizen versager ist wie das sowie
der moment empfunden was ich denn jetzt
passiert also ich habe verstanden dass
es so ist wie sich sondern das ist es so
ergangen ist bisher mit dem
technologisch und ist also so mitteilt
hat es ist der platz war anstelle von
koffern von papi und mami
endlich ist klein handlich ist weisen
drehen als ausgestanden ist merkt man
dass sich jetzt wirksamer verstecken
nach maß
wenn sie zeit und müssen diesen
kalibrieren die den anklage einfach aufs
trittbrett nichts das ist amtlich
aussehen muss er nicht der ganz grosse
stein vom herzen und ich habe eigentlich
für die ganze welt hat mir jetzt garden
und jetzt akzeptieren so wie bei bse
moment ist wahnsinnig erleichtert
[Musik]
pascals elternhaus her sind er und
bruder yannic aufgewachsen
[Musik]
77 du brauchst du sensible rischen sehe
dann ehrlich
jannik roling früheren und die
bauausgaben sehen
wenn jetzt auch immer noch der haut des
vereins weiterbildete der ganze mist
wieder erstaunt wie die aber viel
unterwegs bin
also hat die deutsche bahn im kasseler
begleitet
du hast die ganze vorbereitung und alles
wirkt auf mich extrem professionell
ich glaube dass titel an
weißt du nicht so wirst was du genau das
machen was du jetzt erst richtig
kilogramm ursprungs kaputt macht aber
ich glaube der mutiert nach 60 sekunden
komm zu mir und meinem sohn nach linie
holen so zu einer großen klappe das ebit
um arminia vorwurf machen zeigen hat
schon wieder auf das angesprochene sexy
und schön ist jetzt dass wir so klug und
das mit dem weg zu machen
so half angesprochen hat sicherlich seit
montagabend die zahlen quasi und was ist
rum sagt man es doch und jugendlichen
und gaden und irgendwie der schritt das
übersetzen oder versprechen dass frau
glauben auf einen jugendlichen oder
erwachsenen schwarz also das zentrum
kommen oder aus dem mobilnetz sei dank
das muss schon schwierig sie für die
ganze zeit und du hast es nicht sein
großvater ist wahnsinnig wichtige
wünsche mir als fußballer begleitet mich
sind viele andere zusammen mit sehr viel
zusammen erlebt
und immer mehr als 60 du schaffst das
ist ein wahnsinnig gern kann ich aber
gemerkt hier bin ich mir unsicher die
conny mit einer situation gegenüber dem
großvater und sich damit relativ langsam
das hat mein vater tenno
durchgeschüttelt dass er das nicht schon
früh erfahren hat dass er mit dem
früheren schalke noch einmal
auseinandersetzen und ungarn
[Musik]
also später also der basta hätte basin
großvater im spitalgarten zwei wochen
bevor es der opec stoffe nicht
[Musik]
das alte team opa ist von der
schwierigsten sie einfach irgendwie
weitermachen und irgendwie werde ich
sagen ich bin ganz genau so pascal
obispo pierre du bist einer von der
wichtigsten menschen im lager und die
wartezeit ich sage und ich hoffe durch
mit logan ich bin schwul und pascal für
mich ist dass es bis juni nicht kennt
aber ich kenne die um die liebe de als
mensch und als zweiter in 300 gehandelt
mehr handys mit android ist zeigt dass
wir das richtige leben und das ist
wahnsinnig schön ich bisher flog sie das
ist der trick macht
[Musik]
seit gut einem jahr wohnt pascal mit
partner mike zusammen
gemeinsam bauen sie ihr haus um
darüber wird dann von schwarz-rot besser
langsam
am anfang habe ich mit dem was ich seh
oder was denkt die mutter und oma und
mädchen wieder zurück so dass das
akzeptiert wird das machbare sehr
schätze sie sehr niedrig
kurz gut heute vorladen wir bringen ist
schnell die ohne das grün im moment sie
sich hinter dem höchsten ja ja das ist
doch super der fördermittel für den
moment schon jetzt sollten 23
das bedeutet auch dass das die meisten
stemberg begleitet es ist megaschön und
mega wichtig immer wieder trieb das
gerät und am anfang ist riesig sie das
drucker automatisch was übers tor
die domino und zwangen oder salopp du
musst das machen aber jetzt wenn man
wenn man da wachsen wir und wenn ich
weiß ja in die familie hat einen
intercity
das ist schön und wenn ich jetzt bald
zurück dann schon mit dem nächsten comic
familie eine neutrale xp das ist
eigentlich negativ ziehen und jetzt
sowie die rettungssanitäter der wako das
ist schön und die schätze sehr und bin
mega dankbar dass er das mitmacht und ja
damals
also könnte
als sichere leibliche mutter sehr sehr
nervös auf die zieht wasser und das
haben wir beide noch nicht sagen
[Musik]
es ist schon längst teil sehr nervös
aber auch sehr neugierig was ist woche
und vor allem weil also ehe familie ist
sehr wahrscheinlich dass sauerland gehen
jedes problem kann mit dem arbeiten was
da ist heuer besonders kreativ und lange
brennen autos mit wertnote und verdiene
ich dass ich so wird vom einen zum
anderen weil er das coming out auch wie
groß die situation ist und in china
selber wunder dass das ganze machen
[Musik]
seit 13 jahren arbeitet pascal erlachner
als turnlehrer die heilige auf und
lehrerinnen und lehrern ja das ist so
ein ort wo es möglich ist wenn er freie
rede wenn die dann kam anfang juni
wieder angefangen hauslehrer
systematisch erprobt mit den frau und
ihr kind ein ist das weiß im juni juni
dries gewartet lehrerinnen und lehrern
lade und dem rest von dick macht und
dass sie lehrerin kollegen bei medizin
und theologie muss öffentlich sagen und
und wahrscheinlich reaktion genau
richtig wir bieten heute einfaches zeit
und mit begleitete und die genauigkeit
und am anfang nicht so spannend die
frage ist natürlich zu wachsen ja am
anfang erzählt ausspannen die frage
gartow wie ist da raus und mitte zieht
sich ja auch etliche wurden mit frage
überhaupt der prozess scheint überhaupt
nicht für euch selbst fremd sie
inspiriert und und griff man offiziell
mit ethischer so lang erklärt und du
bist genau gleich noch die post
gefordert annex i bekannt
es ist die stimme der wahnsinnig
spannende prozessen auf dem es am anfang
nie reagiert haben wir jetzt reagieren
und schritt vorwärts
ist eine krise der gesellschaft gibt es
immer noch orte oder erwachsene lied das
gefühl sie ist wie pädophilie und wenn
man wahnsinnig vorsichtige show als
leeres gerade im sportunterricht denn
kommt man zu wenig für den älteren der
vorwurf könne jeder hat dieses manko
dieser burgkirchen der ähnliches gefühl
leben erinnern hat und wird sagen oder
wo frau ist oft das gefühl dass eine von
uns herzlich willkommen
heute unterrichtet pascal eine neunte
klasse mit zehn verschiedenen
nationalitäten
die schulleitung weiß dass sich pascal
als schiedsrichter outen will aber schon
besprochen
das könnte die reaktion ist von den
eltern auf die npd radio grosse
diskussionen auslösen also dass man
nicht immer das du tabuisieren sondern
dass man sie ausspricht
esra sie dass sie entweder anderer
kultureller kreis oder vor die nach
nationalität woher sie aus dem römer ist
vielleicht das thema boni akzeptiert
wird und kratzte die entweder an der
diskussion bitte mit alten alex und
jonas seite bitte neu große matador
hintendrauf perfekt machte
rossi zum beruf gruppe schülerinnen und
schüler die nächste höchste stufe und es
geht mir eigentlich lustige situationen
der turbo unter den anbietern sowie
witzleben auch als minister nicht einmal
böse höhere maalouf oder schnitzel
schwule bass und da gehört man ab und
stach und hinter rettet nicht das so und
das ist nicht die apotheker verletzt und
matic reaktionen von der schülerinnen
und schüler aber nun jetzt volker
angesprochen wurden entziehen freund
oder mit wem wollen sie zusammen
sie sehen mich getraut sich mit fragen
der schülerinnen und schüler
jeder nazis privat habe ich aber ruhig
öffentliche position aus leder mit
schülerinnen und schüler versprechen die
tigers ist es so und glaube nach dem
outing danke peter sowieso nie ums thema
sie in capital wird sogar noch schätze
wenn man alltags können treten also und
wenn sie den märkten ist ganz normal da
dran ich freue mich also dass das macht
mit der euro wieder wahnsinnig starke
auftritte
st gallen ende september ist sie wie ich
freue mich auf dieses spiel mit euch
zusammen
gallen thun top-bedingungen schönes
stadion gutes gutes spiel gute
ausgangslage wo ich in der letzten zeit
immer ein bisschen respekt hatte ist
wenn es schneller kontakt also dann
einfach auch versucht mir zu helfen ist
das inside outside dieses zusammenspiel
im team ist wichtig das wird sich im
matsch nachher deutlich zeigen
jetzt seien sie kritisch das sind jetzt
die stand ein vierter offizieller
womöglich schon häufig damals schaffte
unterdessen traf der spät an
wunderschönen stadion und cool wenn
jetzt das so versteht man darf durch
gemacht dass ich so
es gebe ja gerade nicht gut aussieht sie
diese so dass es spielen die nur nicht
als schiedsrichter mit dem boden zieht
es den druck noch heute wird jeder in
christi dass der höhere wert
sicher wird man am anfang die trophy
gartenstraße wo das ist ermutigend aber
schlussendlich für alle kommt also danke
dass ich das ist nicht das was zählt als
schiedsrichter team wäre ist dass ich
homosexuell ja und das hat für mich
natürlich wahnsinnig erleichtert dass
ich auch dass ich auf verrät er über das
ganze dass man deutlich machen dass man
auch die schönen erlebnis wenn man mit
dem partner teilen
ich hoffe teller nicht irgend möglich
muss verschwinden und dass das macht
alles viel einfacher und ist ein
gewisser druck gefallen
darf sie was männer sind
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
nein
auch wenn kommen angeführt
schiedsrichter mutter margrit und bruder
yannic verfolgen die partie am fernseher
und schreiben pascal sms tatsächlich vor
jedem match machen also lustig zurück
rituale
normalität ist eine farbe schnitt groß
[Musik]
es ist immer noch die sagen das war mir
zurück nur der herbergen wir haben es in
der hand muss immer nervöser als wenn
man gut ist und alles sauber dieter
hundt hat ja das macht man es nur spiel
bist du und ist ebenso bist so der
letzten minute soll man das mit vier
oder noch zum nur bis jetzt gut
[Applaus]
was die schiedsrichter während des
spiels kommunizieren bleibt
normalerweise unter ihnen heute machen
sie eine ausnahme
gut spielen heute 1800 touren zu haben
tiefer achtung
wie heißt du macht ihr spaß
ok
mitspieler
welche waffen gebracht
das ist klasse aber das ist diese
verantwortung vom fußballverband und der
frachtsparte braucht
für uns muss die jetzt im moment wenn
man das stadion das ist das noch mal
sehr genießt aber wir müssen den fokus
hat das casting minute schafft es
passiert
und diese aufmerksamkeit braucht er
es ist ein intensives spiel von der
ersten minute an
[Gelächter]
es ist klar ja das klappt doch auch dort
trifft die stark
blutflecken
mit
[Applaus]
ja
vielleicht aus mieten strothotte
[Applaus]
ich habe dies klar belegt das roxy ist
stoppt
[Applaus]
afp
frauen 1
intensive hauptsächlich das geht
zusätzlich engagiert so schnitt ungefähr
ab es gibt so viel material hatte mal
bestraft werden
die rote karte nach 17 minuten gesehen
nicht so dass ssv buer ihre kinder unter
und das st galler spielen könnte alex
cole auf der maxi wie wichtig ist ihm
zusammenarbeitet ist das so darüber
seien als vierter offizieller umfasst
über das nummer 63 machen
für ihn ist rot und durch die musik der
linie hätte vom sechzehner selbst die
chance raub und das stete sache sehr
schwierig sie auch noch nach richtig
entschieden
die zweite halbzeit bringt keine großen
aufreger mehr st gallen gewinnt drei zu
null
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nein gemacht wenn man auch im spiel
hätten wir es feedback und von irgendwo
völlig unter die gürtellinie geht aber
mit tisch mit sorry gewöhnt und ich
versuche mit der ybbs gesprochen
wenn ich aber merke es ist ein völlig
falsches völlig for the last der
durchaus akzeptieren ich so wie der sid
dritte so akzeptieren
ich verfolge im bus casini karriere als
schiedsrichter
ja von anfang an engagiert zu niedrige
noten ja alles ausgeschnitten
alles muss jederzeit jeden artikel geht
die fotos noch nie fertig
haus des fussballs muri bei bern
pascal bekommt von seinem coach bruno
grossen regelmäßige feedbacks zu seinen
leistungen was gottes ist genau das
problem vom modus poppig im jockey modus
luk ina lottogeschichte aktion hinter
normalen jobs oder aufschnitt du weißt
genau das passiere hier wird sich
entscheiden
teamchef investieren so dass hier
irgendwas passiert oder blieb staffel im
jogging modus bringt sich so gar nicht
da musst du ja sicher mehr stellen würde
krieg körpersprachlich wenn es schwierig
wird wenn es heikel wird wenn der
angriffe wird der kanal mit körperstatur
und domizil kraft wunder hinter sich
stellen kann jetzt blüht auf distanz
halten so einfach da muss einfach
starten ist sehr setzte der fall wenn es
hektisch als niveau ja einfach mit der
großen gäste katali weg bringt dann
musst du musst es schaffen dass sie mir
forderung
die beiden analysieren auch die rote
karte der entscheid sei richtig findet
großen gefallen denn wo du in
schildesche ist rotich concorde dafür
aber das spiel ist noch ein portal das
mit linken seite steht
du wartest mit der rote teppich ist auch
nachts wird da schon ausgewechselt es
darum geht aber konnten die anträge
entscheiden muss nicht mehr diskutieren
das war damals bruno grossen gehörte zu
den ersten beim fußballverband dem
pascal anvertraute dass er schwul ist
die fußball-welt schaut wirklich als
wurde ich sehe dass ich es häufig
speckgürtel um die hoffe einfach das
thema homosexualität eigentlich krank
sagt späth oder die sexuelle energie
generell bei mir wird der sonne die
frage stellt das ist doch einfach jeder
schwierig wird das ich noch mal ja ich
verstehe das nicht ganz warum es im
fußball aus temarii
ich hoffe einfach dass fan lager und
dort später das positive hatte offene
madrid negativ stadion kleinholz in
olten pascal erlachner trainiert mit
einem schiedsrichter assistenten
es ist ein besonderer tag die zeitung
blick ist dabei den journalisten ist
seit langem bekannt dass pascal schwul
ist heute ist er bereit und gibt dazu
sein erstes interview
das hat immer vorfahrt 20 eine
vorstellung dass eben auch das thema
darf der öffentlichkeit bringen und sich
sicher sind was sie tat das dritte
nieder
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es ist spezieller moment wenn so viele
da sie kaum rauch in einem stadion ist
irgendwie anders studie scott nicht
grundsätzlich sondern um fußball und
jetzt so viel für mich als
schiedsrichter für die sache ist
speziell aber schöner moment ist das
interview erscheint dauert es nur noch
wenige tage
das ist so ein moment wo muss man es ist
megaschön squeeze ist so positiv positiv
ich vor freude und flugs flügen das ist
labor betragen und das jetzt darauf dass
er schöne kombis glaubens schütze mit
durchsagen bis jetzt führt er mit mir
selber im moment also wenn zurück dann
kanns bereich outing da ist zum einen
knick bekommen
als teenager ist auch viel unterwegs
aber jetzt nicht auch scu die
verursachen könne
so erreichen oder so artig also das was
mir passt
alles vielleicht ist das
[Musik]
erst mal einige flüge das ist ein
bisschen viel monika das ist mein ziel
ist dass irgendein ich fürchte
[Musik]
es schenkt hat sich so viel die probleme
und sind die enkel sowie und als pilot
ich mit der übernahme und tata steel
sind und sich so stöhr im moment
genießen und versicherer
[Musik]
entsprechend landing 16 anteile komplett
ein
[Musik]
pascal und partner mike haben ein
wochenende mit vielen schlagzeilen
hinter sich hat dass man über das direkt
das land erreicht und jetzt auch alle
froh wenn sie abnimmt das ist klar wenn
es zur normalität über gott und das sehr
schön sehr schön der spätromantik am
main die schülerinnen und schüler ring
genau richtig macht übersetzt und 230
hohe und der fcz also ihre sind die expo
xxi in frage gestellt und sie mir
wahnsinnig berührt auch hier keine schon
richtig joker und der mir die ganze
sache unterstützt also ich glaube was
ist was ausgelaufen ist und wie stolz er
ist das ein verändertes macht er sich
sehr schön gefunden wurde wie cool das
ist eine tolle stadt und macht also
wirklich schöne sache aber das haben wir
alle gerne du hast du aber du hast recht
ich es machen wie wichtig jetzt den
aufstieg dass sie die route machen dass
sie wird der fokus von schlecker jetzt
[Musik]
kurz oder lang
namen wie häufig sie ganze dauert in rot
malt wie gewünscht in rumänien
dieser prozess ist nicht nein
so unbedingt dem ist positiv wo sie zu
das hat mir nächste periode meistern und
sage ich auf die hitze begannen sie habe
hier die fürs am boden und jedoch
anschlagziele so lange gekämpft und
optimiert für mich dass das ist es
wichtig die ganze
lausanne letzten sonntag nun weist die
ganze schweiz
dass pascal schwul ist es ist sein
erstes spiel nach dem coming out
[Applaus]
brauche ich mit sehr unaufgeregt ja so
gut geführtes verfahren sonntag hat die
ente verschmelzen soll zwischen
[Applaus]
pacmag reichsten weltkrieg fast völlig
ja ja ja ja ja aber ich sehe es so nicht
kommen nicht funktioniert
das ist ja es gibt absolut ja selber
[Musik]
respektieren durch ein spezielles
gemachten forderungen und dass das
laufen geschmack achtung achtung
darunter
[Applaus]
[Musik]
danke
weißt du gleich darauf sein was positive
licht riesenstein vom herzen
wiso-tipp reaktionen vor augen spiele so
muss sie
ja schon
[Musik]
hey was hättest auch brauchen
bergkamen
[Musik]
diese reichten nicht aus
euro
[Musik]